she was he had said more than a monarch
she defined an era and with that
reflection the american president was
the first to sign the book of condolence
at britain's embassy in washington
she led with enduring strength and
dignity he wrote
good morning for all of you
she was a great lady
we're so delighted we got to meet her
at the white house the lowering of the
stars and stripes was a salute to the
closest of friendships america the
colony which split from british rule and
yet became so fondly entwined from afar
this is cnn breaking
news to go straight to london and so it
was that the news of her death dominated
everything and will do for days
queen elizabeth ii britain's longest
reigning monarch has died at the age of
96. for the woman who had met 13 of the
last 14 presidents from truman
eisenhower and kennedy to obama trump
and biden she knew them all and she
charmed them all the so-called special
relationship was one she fostered
through so many american presidencies
over the border canada a commonwealth
nation and a prime minister with a
deeply personal reflection
in
a complicated world
her steady grace
and resolve
brought comfort and strength to us all
canada
is in mourning
she was one of my favorite people in the
world
and i will miss her so
she was head of state in nations far
beyond britain but where the institution
was increasingly questioned the fondness
for her was never in doubt
this time of mourning will pass but the
deep respect and warm regard in which
australians have always held for her
majesty will never fade
last summer's g7 meeting in cornwall was
it would turn out the last time many of
today's leaders saw her in person
the french people are also in mourning
president macron said the one who rubbed
shoulders with the giants of the 20th
century on the path of history has gone
to join them
she was above the turbulent geopolitics
of the decades she reigned through and
yet so often her duty was to navigate it
all the tributes from around the world
suggest a duty well done mark stone sky
news in washington